die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
pareigis bekommen an diesem freitagabend
tennis und fußball später der sendung
von norbert lehmann
denn erst einmal schauen wir was
politisch wichtiges passiert ist
mehr waffen hilfe für die ukraine
die eu gibt weitere 500 millionen euro
kiew bittet um kampfjets und
raketenabwehrsysteme
weniger essen in den tank wegen der
nahrungsmittelkrise durch den ukraine
krieg will das umweltministerium den
einsatz von biosprit einschränken
und lagebericht rechtsextremismus laut
innenministerium haben hunderte
mitarbeiter der sicherheitsbehörden ein
gestörtes verhältnis zur demokratie
für die gruppe der sieben wichtigsten
westlichen industriestaaten dreht sich
zurzeit fast alles um den ukraine krieg
und seine folgen derzeit treffen sich
die g7 außenministerin und minister in
weißen haus schleswig holstein dabei
kündigte der eu außenbeauftragte borel
für die ukraine weitere 500 millionen
euro militärhilfe an damit erhöht sich
die unterstützung der eu auf zwei
milliarden euro hier sehen sie das an
den balken zum vergleich deutschland hat
neben waffenlieferungen mehr als eine
milliarde euro militärhilfe eingeplant
die usa haben der ukraine waffen und
munition im wert von etwa dreieinhalb
milliarden euro zugesagt oder sie
bereits geliefert dann die post
berichtet je stärker sich abzeichnet
dass der krieg lange dauern könne desto
mehr beschäftigt auch die frage wie die
ukraine langfristig mit waffen
unterstützt werden könne das hierfür
zusätzlich zugesagte geld der eu sei
allerdings weiterhin nicht für
kampfflugzeuge vorgesehen
nein diese 500 millionen sind vorgesehen
für schwere waffen wir haben das bereits
geliefert gepanzerte fahrzeuge panzer
schwere artillerie munition eben die
dinge die gebraucht werden für diese art
von krieg
es ist sehr wichtig zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt dass wir den druck auf
wladimir putin hochhalten
der ukrainische aussenminister der zu
gast war dankte für sehr konstruktive
gespräche nannte aber auch mehr
geschwindigkeit bei den
waffenlieferungen an
eine situation in der man kämpft und die
waffen die dafür benötigt werden immer
noch auf dem weg sind ist nicht
hilfreich
gastgeberin berbalk betonte neben der
dauerhaften unterstützung der ukraine
gelte die solidarität auch moldau dessen
außenminister ebenfalls zu gast war
zudem weitete berbalk den blick auf
globale folgen des krieges vor allem die
nahrungsmittelknappheit wie putin
bewusst schüre indem er getreideexporte
aus der ukraine unmöglich mache wir
können derzeit erst die spitze des
eisbergs sehen wir wissen alle wenn die
klimakrise diesen sommer weltweit voll
durchschlägt wird die situation noch
schlimmer
[Musik]
auch hier gelte es entschlossen und
gemeinsam zu agieren für die
ministerinnen und minister der
nato-länder steht gleich im anschluss
ihr nächstes treffen auf dem programm am
wochenende in berlin
auch wegen der drohenden
nahrungsmittelkrise diskutiert die
politik derzeit über den sinn von
biosprit im kern geht es um diese frage
soll potenzielles essen im tank lampen
oder nicht besser doch auf dem teller
nur ein beispiel zur großen ordnung neun
prozent der weltweiten getreideernte
gehen derzeit in die herstellung von
biokraftstoffen auch raps mais und
zuckerrüben werden verarbeitet einer
tankstelle ist der biosprit in benzin
oder diesel bereits beigemischt so deckt
deutschland etwa sechseinhalb prozent
seines gesamten kraftstoffbedarf und
überzeugt
e10 benzin oder b7 diesel
umweltschonendere biokraftstoffe die zu
einem geringen teil aus pflanzlichen
produkten hergestellt werden eigentlich
weist ziel diesen pflanzlichen anteil
sogar zu erhöhen jetzt kehrt wenn ihr
der bundesumweltministerin in zeiten wo
durch den krieg in der ukraine
lebensmittelmärkte global gesehen unter
druck kommen uns eine globale
hungerkrise droht in einer solchen zeit
muss der teller vorrang vor den tankern
11,7 millionen hektar ackerfläche gibt
es in deutschland auf rund 757 1000
hektar werden pflanzen für die
kraftstoffproduktion angebauter meisten
raps für biodiesel getreide zuckerrüben
und mais für e10 benzin auf diesen
flächen so lembkes vorschlag sollen bald
nahrungsmittel wachsen reaktionen wir
unterstützen das wir wollen die
beimischungsquote reduzieren darüber
können wir relativ schnell fläche
gewinnen und zwar relevant fläche
gewinnen die wir sinnvoller nutzen könnt
für die ernährung von menschen firmen
die aus pflanzen bioethanol für e10
benzin herstellen fürchten mehr schaden
als nutzen den bio ethanol brauchen auch
andere branchen das ist beispielsweise
die chemische industrie das ist die
pharmazeutische industrie und das ist
die lebensmittelwirtschaft und all diese
wirtschaftsbeteiligten die wären ja auch
davon betroffen wenn jetzt die
produktion von ethanol und agraralkohol
in deutschland eingeschränkt würde
kritik auch vom koalitionspartner fdp
zum einen müsste dann noch mehr öl
importiert werden außerdem führe lembkes
vorschlag zu einem höheren ausstoß von
treibhausgasen im verkehr kritisiert
bundesverkehrsminister volker wissing
das sei mit den klimazielen der
bundesregierung nicht vereinbar und
nicht abgestimmt
erstmals seit ende märz hat kanzler
scholz heute wieder mit dem russischen
präsidenten putin telefoniert
nachdem das massaker von butscher wenige
tage später bekannt wurde hatte es
zwischen den beiden kein gespräch mehr
gegeben
scholz forderte in dem 75 minütigen
telefonat heute einen waffenstillstand
vor dem gespräch stand der kanzler
erstmals im verteidigungsausschuss des
bundestages rede und antwort zum lied
hier hilfe für die ukraine
lasst uns sagen
gut eine stunde nimmt sich der
bundeskanzler zeit für den
verteidigungsausschuss längst nicht lang
genug um alle fragen zu beantworten denn
noch ist scholz mit seinem auftritt
zufrieden
ganz so super finden dass nicht alle das
gespräch mit stolz wird erwartungsgemäß
ganz unterschiedlich bewertet der
bundeskanzler scholz hat wortreich
ausgeführt aber konkret auf die fragen
des ausschusses nicht geantwortet wird
es weitere schwere waffen geben was sind
die lieferbedingungen kann sich die
ukraine auf deutschland verlassen diese
dinge sind nicht angesprochen worden
großen linien den kurs der
bundesregierung in aller
entschlossenheit und entschiedenheit
geschildert unsere friedensordnung zu
verteidigen so weit so erwartbar für
irritationen allerdings sorgen mehrere
abgeordnete der fdp die frühzeitig den
ausschuss verlassen und den kanzler mit
ähnlichen worten kritisieren wie die
opposition als freidemokraten sind wir
der auffassung dass er hier die chance
hatte zu erklären wie der ukraine besser
helfen gegen putins angeregt diese
chance hat er leider nicht genutzt
treten der spannungen innerhalb der
koalition offen zutage die
ausschussvorsitzende will sich der
kritik ihres parteifreundes nicht
anschließen natürlich haben viele
abgeordnete sehr viele fragen gestellt
da gibt es halt den 1 er hat das gefühl
gehabt seine frage ist nicht beantwortet
worden aber das ist bei netto sprechzeit
des kanzlers vor 35 minuten jetzt auch
nicht wirklich überraschend nach einer
sitzung des fraktionsvorstands rudert
der fdp-abgeordnete farbe wieder zurück
kündigte an seinen posten als
verteidigungspolitischer sprecher
abzugeben so wird aus einem
vermeintlichen eklat um olaf scholz eine
politposse der fdp
in der ukraine wurde heute mit einer
voranhörung der erste
kriegsverbrecherprozess gegen einen
russischen soldaten eröffnet seit dem
einmarsch hierfür russland vor bereits
zahlreiche kriegsverbrechen verübt zu
haben und stützt sich dabei auch auf
berichte von internationalen
menschenrechtsorganisationen
achse konrad über das verfahren
gerade mal 21 jahre alt ist war die ms
jungen haft die erscheinung töten
feindlicher soldaten im kampf gehört zu
seiner aufgabe hier aber war das opfer
ein unbewaffneter zivilisten in einem
video hat er den ukrainischen behörden
die tat gestanden die näheren umstände
der aufnahme sind nicht bekannt mit
anderen war war die ms demnach auf dem
rückzug in einem gestohlenen privatauto
auf der straße ein mann mit fahrrad der
telefonierte aus angst er könnte die
russischen soldaten verraten kam der
befehl zu schießen sagt er und war dem
schuss in den kopf aus dem offenen
fenster des fahrzeugs in dem er saß ein
kriegsverbrechen für das war dem jetzt
lebenslang droht die
generalstaatsanwältin der ukraine hier
mit außenministerin berbalk vor drei
tagen in butter untersucht mehr als
10.000 potenzielle kriegsverbrechen
kriegsverbrecher zu bestrafen gelingt
nur äußerst selten denn es muss zunächst
beweise für ein verbrechen gebe und dann
muss der täter auch noch verhaftet
werden solange aber in seinem land
schutz findet wird er nicht verhaftet
und dadurch auch nicht verurteilt sobald
aber ein kriegsverbrecher einen fuß in
ein fremdes land wie deutschland selbst
besteht für ihn ein hohes risiko erkannt
verhaftet und dann auch verurteilt zu
werden nur selten sind die verbrechen so
leicht zu belegen wie in diesem fall aus
den ersten kriegstagen ein
überwachungsvideo als beweis dokument
der besitzer eines autohauses und ein
wachmann im gespräch mit russischen
soldaten sie werden durchsucht die
situation scheint geklärt doch dann
kommen die russen zurück und erschießen
die männer von hinten
minuten später plündern die schützen das
büro ihre opfer sie prosten sich zu ihre
gesichter sind gut zu erkennen
doch auch wenn sie noch am leben sind zu
einer anklage wird es wohl nie kommen
motto kiew haben ukrainische truppen die
russischen invasoren ja zurückgedrängt
der preis war hoch viele tote zerbombte
häuser zerstörte strassen eine besondere
lage gibt es nun in einem der nördlichen
vororte der hauptstadt denn in dem x5
das wasser die touristischen truppen
aufzuhalten die sind jetzt weg die
fluten sind aber noch da ein bericht
unseres reporters dara hassanzadeh
dieser see ist kein naturreservat er ist
entstanden im krieg norden von kiew hat
die ukrainische armee den damm des
wienflusses gesprengt um das vorrücken
der russischen panzer auf die hauptstadt
dort zu stoppen
nur weil alles hier geflutet wurde
konnten die russen nicht weiterkommen
einer ihrer panzer hat versucht das
wasser zu durchqueren sie mussten ihnen
dann raus ziehen sie waren danach
dreckig wie der teufel
der nachbar sammelt sein trinkwasser
jetzt den pool er ist einer der wenigen
im dorf der sauberes trinkwasser aus der
tiefe pumpen kann ihre toiletten dürfen
sie nicht mehr nutzen die kanalisation
ist überschwemmt die keller sind
vollgelaufen um kiew zu retten haben sie
die fluten ihrer häuser in kauf genommen
jewgeni wurde im auto von russischen
soldaten beschossen eine kugel traf
seine mutter
wir haben nur eine ambulante klinik hier
ohne operationssaal meine mutter ist
innerhalb von zwei tagen gestorben sie
ist verblutet wir konnten sie von hier
nicht weg bringen die russen haben
niemanden aus dem dorf gelassen
das wasser werden sie im dorf dem ide
vielleicht schon bis zum ende dieses
sommers ab gepumpt haben ihre erinnerung
an die furchtbare zeit wird bleiben
gestern hatte finnland erklärt möglichst
rasch der nato beitreten zu wollen heute
gab es diese meldung aus moskau das
russische energieunternehmen rao stellt
ab morgen die stromlieferungen und das
nachbarland finnland ein als grund
wurden ausstehende zahlungen genannt
nach finnischen angaben liefert russland
aktuell rund zehn prozent des
verbrauchten stroms die
energiesicherheit sei gewährleistet und
so weit zum konflikt mit russland
in jerusalem ist die getötete
palästinensische journalist in china
boakye beigesetzt worden tausende
menschen kamen zum friedhof nahe der
altstadt dabei gab es gewaltsame
auseinandersetzungen zwischen
israelischer sicherheitskräften und
demonstrierenden
am mittwoch war die bekannte
al-dschasira-reporterin getötet worden
bei einem schusswechsel des israelischen
militärs mit militanten palästinensern
der für ihren tod verantwortlich ist ist
weiter unklar
bei den sicherheitsbehörden von bund und
ländern in deutschland arbeiten mehr
rechtsextremisten als bislang bekannt
327 bedienstete sind dort innerhalb von
drei jahren aufgefallen weil sie bezüge
zum rechtsextremismus oder zur szene der
sogenannten reichs bürger haben das
zeigt ein neuer lagebericht den
bundesinnenminister den phaser heute
vorstellte klaus brodbeck mit den
einzelheiten
es ist das zweite lagebild über
rechtsextreme umtriebe in den
sicherheitsbehörden innerhalb von nur
zwei jahren die zahl der untersuchten
behörden erhöht die methoden verfeinert
die auswertung genauer es geht um viel
wird die integrität der
sicherheitsbehörden von innen heraus
geschädigt dann ist dies besonders
gefährlich für rechtsstaat und
demokratie denn die sicherheitsbehörden
stehen hier für den schutz unserer
demokratie niemals für das gegenteil
außerdem wirkt das handeln von
extremisten aus den sicherheitsbehörden
heraus ein hohes gefahrenpotenzial sind
mit besonderen eingriffsbefugnissen
ausgestattet und haben zugriff auf
sensible daten
sie haben spezialwissen und mitunter
zugang zu waffen polizei und
verfassungsschutz von bund und ländern
bk bundeswehr zoll die
sicherheitsbehörden haben rund
355.000 beschäftigte zu 860
verdachtsfällen kam es in den
vergangenen drei jahren davon
327 verbrachten tatsächliche
anhaltspunkte für verfassungsfeindliche
verhalten im gesamtvergleich eine
geringe zahl doch die hat es in sich das
ergebnis ist es darf ich so deutlich
sagen erschreckend denn bei 60 prozent
der personen bei denen tatsächliche
anhaltspunkte vorliegen haben im schnitt
jeweils vier kennen linien in die
rechtsextremistische szene seit die afg
insgesamt vom verfassungsschutz
beobachtet werden darf gilt auch die
mitgliedschaft dort als kriterium
künftige zahlen könnten also steigen
entsetzen heute morgen einer
regionalbahn bei aachen plötzlich steht
ein mann wahllos auf andere passagiere
ein und verletzt dabei fünf menschen
für keines der opfer besteht
lebensgefahr
schlimmeres konnte wohl nur verhindert
werden weil es drei passagieren gelang
den angreifer zu überwältigen
der 31 jährige stammt aus dem irak und
galt dabei den behörden 2017 als
islamistischer prüfer für die tat heute
gibt es allerdings nach angaben der
ermittler bisher keine hinweise auf ein
islamistisches motiv
am sonntag wird in nordrhein westfalen
ein neuer landtag gewählt und letzte
umfragen und bevölkerungsreichsten
bundesland deuten auf ein enges rennen
zwischen cdu und spd
im zdf-politbarometer
kommt die cdu von ministerpräsident
weist auf 32 prozent die spd mit
herausforderer kutschaty auf 29 die fdp
liegt bei 6 prozent die fdp 7 die grünen
bei 17 prozent die linke bei drei
prozent etwa ein drittel der
wahlberechtigten hat sich noch nicht
entschieden zum ende des wahlkampfs
ralph goldmann
ministerpräsident und
cdu-spitzenkandidat hendrik wüst beendet
den wahlkampf in einer fahrzeug
produktionshalle im münsterland es ist
das erste mal dass er um wählerstimmen
werben muss sein ziel dass wir das
stärkste ergebnis kriegen von allen
parteien die anträgen dass wir vorne
sind und dass wir damit einen
regierungsauftrag haben damit nordrhein
westfalen auch in zukunft gut und stabil
regiert werden kann auch er will
ministerpräsident werden
oppositionsführer und herausforderer
thomas kutschaty vor zwei stunden in
köln laut politbarometer liefern sich
seine spd und die cdu ein kopf an kopf
rennen wir sind jetzt richtig heiß
geworden wir sind heiß darauf die wahl
zu gewinnen und ich sage euch wir werden
am sonntag diese wahl gewinnen in
nordrhein westfalen
derzeit regiert noch die cdu mit der fdp
deren spitzenkandidat joachim stamp will
das auch weiter tun auch wenn es laut
umfragen mit einer neuauflage von
schwarz gelb schwierig werden könnte
starten sie uns dass wir so stark werden
am sonntag dass keine regierung ohne uns
gebildet werden kann dann geht es weiter
mit nordrhein-westfalen nach vorne nicht
zurück die grünen könnten mit der
landesvorsitzenden mona neubaur aber die
fdp überflügeln eine
regierungsbeteiligung ist nicht
unwahrscheinlich
vielen dank nordrhein westfalen braucht
politik mit haltung politik die erklärt
politik die ehrlich kommuniziert die
lernfähig ist nach so vielen krisen auch
die afg mit dem fraktionsvorsitzenden
markus wagner wird wohl wieder im
landtag vertreten sein eine
regierungsbeteiligung mit der afg
schließen aber alle anderen parteien aus
nur ein erster linie werden wir auf
unserer alleinstellungsmerkmale
verweisen und werden darauf verweisen
dass es eine starke opposition braucht
die regierung kontrolliert einer von
ihnen jedenfalls wird ministerpräsident
werden hendrik wüst oder thomas
kutschaty am sonntag wird sich
entscheiden wer in der wählergunst die
nase vorn hat
entschieden hat sich aber schon wer im
tennis gewonnen hat norbert alexanders
wären schon wieder schon wieder drittes
spiel dritter zwei satz sieg in rom der
olympiasieger kommt in schwung knapp
eine woche vor den french open
im prestigeträchtigen grand slam turnier
heute musste sich sein gegner aus viele
christian gar ihn im viertelfinale
geschlagen geben
es wäre vom boden ja aber das nur ein
sinnbild für seinen einsatz nicht für
seine leistung denn die ist deutlich
besser als in den runden zuvor der erste
satz noch hart umkämpft aber mit dem
besseren ende für zverev schöne rückhand
longline 7 zu 5 das ergebnis danach der
widerstand ist die lehnen christian gar
ihn dahin zwei schnelle breaks im
zweiten satz deutlich die führung für
zverev und dann der matchball zum 6 2
letztlich ein souveräner zweisatzerfolg
der hoffen lässt für das halbfinale
[Applaus]
fußball bundesliga letzter spieltag
morgen entscheidet sich oben wer an den
europäischen wettbewerben teilnimmt und
unten wir absteigen oder in die
relegation muss und vielleicht morgen
auch das letzte spiel von robert
lewandowski im bayern trikot der
stürmerstar könnte den verein verlassen
vielleicht schon nächste saison
er könnte letztmals die meisterschale in
den himmel gehoben haben robert
lewandowski möchte die bayern schon in
diesem sommer verlassen der fc barcelona
lockt angeblich mit einem
dreijahresvertrag
die vertragliche situation ist bekannt
reister sechster 23 über alle anderen
themen die
in gesprächen stattfinden gebe ich keine
auskunft
die nagelsmann plant weiterhin mit dem
33-jährigen nicht zum ersten mal brodelt
die gerüchteküche um den polen sein
berater ch wie knüpft im hintergrund die
fäden doch dem fc barcelona fehlen laut
spanischer presse die geforderten 35 bis
40 millionen die katalanen waren in der
europa league an eintracht frankfurt
gescheitert haben wirtschaftliche
probleme möglich also dass lewandowski
auch weiterhin im bayern trikot
auflaufen wird
schauen wir mal das wort danke schön
kann er ward was feststeht ist dass das
wochenende sonnig wird und trocken mehr
dazu gleich von christa abend um 22 uhr
können sie das heute journal mit
marietta slomka jetzt wünschen das ganze
heute team und ich ihnen noch einen sehr
schönen abend
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum wetter heute
abend unser wochenende wird so nicht
trocken und sehr warm und das fast
überall denn aus dem westen nähert sich
ein hochdruckgebiet das wolken und regen
aus dem land drängt und so lassen heute
nacht auch die letzten schauer im süden
und im nordosten nach in der mitte da
ist es klar unter den wolken die dieser
kräftige westliche wind gebracht hat
haben wir morgen zweistellige
temperaturen 10 11 grad morgen früh in
der mitte bei klarem himmel davids recht
frisch morgen früh bei 4 bis 9 grad am
tag steigen die temperaturen dann aber
schnell am 22 bis 26 grad nur ganz im
norden erreichen wir teils keine 20 grad
das liegt zum einen an dem immer noch
frischen westlichen wind zum anderen an
den wolken die sich hier mit der sonne
abwechseln trotzdem haben wir aber auch
hier sieben bis elf stunden sonne in der
mitte und im süden des landes da scheint
die sonne fast 15 stunden vom himmel nur
an den alpen entwickelt sich abends mal
ein gewitter am sonntag geht das so
weiter viel sonne auch im nordosten bei
fast 30 grad am rheingraben am montag
dann nimmt das ganze ein fulminantes
ende mit gewittern und unwetter poncet
potenzial aus südwesten auf wiedersehen